there's a very popular and I thought
good movie out based on the play which
is based on the novel by Victor Hugo
lame is er habla and I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing it means the miserable
for those who for whom it was not
obvious and when I want to give us a
little bit of context because in that
book play movie there is an attempted
revolution and sometimes people try to
associate it with the French Revolution
but that is not depicting the French
Revolution that people talk about when
they talk about the French Revolution
and so I thought I would give a little
bit of scaffold of French history in the
late 1700s and all the way through the
mid-1800s to give a little bit of
context on the matter so let's start off
in 1789 1789 that's when you have the
French Revolution the first French
Revolution we could say or the French
Revolution which is a the French
Revolution that people talk about when
they're talking about the French
Revolution it was all about deposing
louis xvi and his wife marie antoinette
this is her body there i think she just
got guillotined this is her head it was
a very bloody revolution this is the
storming of the Bastille
all right over here and that starts the
beginning of the first republic in
France the first Republic so there was
there were all these dreams and
aspirations that France would now be a
country of the people not not too
dissimilar to the United States but
revolutions are not so easy or so clean
or so fast and Pitt and France had to go
through several of a long period of pain
before it could really establish itself
as a real Republic but let's keep going
on future further off in history let me
do that in a different color I'll do the
timeline in white so let's fast-forward
let's fast-forward to 1799 1799 this is
when Napoleon Bonaparte comes to power
so and when people talk about Napoleon
they are talking about Napoleon
Bonaparte we'll see that there are other
Napoleon's but if people just say hey
Napoleon did this or that they're
talking about Napoleon Bonaparte so this
is Napoleon comes to
now pull in and he officially ends the
first republic in 1804 because he
declares himself Emperor
but let's fast forward there's many
videos on Khan Academy dealing with the
Napoleonic Wars and the French
Revolution but let's fast-forward to
1815 so let me do that in white again so
you get to 1815 so that's that was about
10 years so I need to go about 16 years
so this is that put us at 1815 right
over there 18 1815 is you essentially
Napoleon faces his Waterloo which was
literally at Waterloo that's why people
talk about facing your Waterloo so that
was he was banished for a little bit to
Elba he was able to come back he had a
hundred actually 111 days in power but
then he was finally defeated and then he
was finally put in to put into exile at
st. Helena's where he died in 1815 you
essentially have the restoration of the
Bourbon monarchy so louis xvi younger
brother louis xvi younger brother comes
to power and they called him louis xviii
so this is louis xviii
which raises a very good question what
happened to Louis the 17th Louis the
17th was Louis the 16th son who died in
prison at the age of 10 in 1795 during
the revolution so let's keep ordering
the Revolutionary period I guess we
could say so this right over here this
straight over here
Napoleon ends let me draw this is
Napoleon's this is Napoleon let me do
this in the same color I did in a pull
the inmate so 1799 to 18 actually 1814
is when Napoleon's reign ended but then
he came back for a little bit so I'll
draw a little bit of a dotted line here
a little dotted line and then 1814 was
the formal restoration of the Bourbon
monarchy and but of course Napoleon
comes back a little bit but after
Waterloo it's really firmly firmly
established so you have the restoration
of the Bourbon monarchy so this is louis
xviii louis xviii and then in 1824 he
dies and he dies child
18 1824 so let's see it's about nine
years so that puts about right over
there
1824 he dies childless and so his
younger brother Charles the tenth comes
to power so then you have Charles the
tenth Charles I'll do all the Bourbons
in purple
Charles Charles the tenth and this is
Charles the tenth right over here and so
let's go a little bit further off into
history you fast-forward all the way to
1830 you fast-forward to 1830 a lot of
discontent and now you have the second
French Revolution you might say oh hey
this must be what lay miserable is all
about no we're not there yet lame is is
not about the second French Revolution
so let's see sometimes called the July
revolution July revolution and this
revolution actually did not it was
successful but did not establish a
republic at this point instead installed
and this whole time there was kind of a
liberalisation the monarchy even when it
was put in power had a kind of a gradual
decline in how much power it had but
after the July revolution they put in
Charles the tents cousin Charles the
tents cousin who was the Duke of Orleans
the Duke of Orleans who is this guy this
guy right over here who Louis Philippe
the first so let me write that so this
is Louis the Louis Philippe Louis
Philippe Philippe the first and so
you're saying Sal you started off this
video talking about lame is you haven't
mentioned lame is yet give me a little
bit of context so now I will give you
context so if you watch the movie it
starts off with Jean Valjean he said
like a shipping shipping place something
where were there were there repairing
ships of some sort that was in 1815
after Waterloo so it was under it was
under louis xviii regime so that's right
over here let me see with the start of
the movie the start of the movie is
right
right about right about there and then
the real climax of the movie which is
this rebellion there's these Newsies
barricades being set up in Paris you
have all these young idealistic folks
who are trying to overthrow the
government this does not happen until
1832
this is 1832 I'll do it right over here
1832 and what catalyzes there are
several things that was catalyzing that
and actually most revolutions are
catalyzed by just economic discontent if
people are rich and happy and have jobs
and aren't getting sick most people
aren't in the mood to revolt but in 1832
as you could imagine the economic
situation was not good there was also a
very very nasty outbreak of cholera and
what really catalyzed the events in lamé
is and they even refer to it in the
movie is the death of this chap right
over here Jean Maximilian Lamarck let me
write him down write the name down
Jean Maxie million and I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing it Lamarque and he dies
in June June of 1832 and he was very
sympathetic to the plight of the poor to
the plight of the common man and he and
and and kind of the the average folks
because that hey look he's our guy in
government and he had an influential
role in government when they died they
when he died they're like look we don't
have anymore
anybody else kind of in a high position
who can speak for us let's use his
funeral as a catalyst for revolt and you
saw that happening in the movie lame is
so lame is that climactic moment that is
the June rebellion of 1832 and it's not
you don't have to have amazing
comprehension of watching movies to
realize that this was unsuccessful so
this right here didn't work didn't work
if it did work it might have been called
the third French Revolution but it was
not it was an unsuccessful
or unsuccessful rebellion really and it
was at Victor Hugo observed it and
that's why he's able to recount it in so
much detail the barricading the young
people the shooting in the streets all
the rest so this is a little bit of
review when people talk about the French
Revolution they're usually talking about
the French Revolution 1789 establishes
or begins to establish the first
Republic it was a successful revolution
the second French Revolution this is the
July revolution this is in 1813 1830
this is puts into power Louis Philippe
the first the person that they're trying
to overthrow in lame is and they don't
establish the Second Republic after this
for the Second Republic we have to go
all the way we have to go all the way to
the revolution we have to go all the way
to the revolution of let me make sure I
can scroll properly go all the way so
let me continue my timeline so this is
Louis Philippe to go 18 years 18 years
to 1848 where you have the third French
Revolution so third French third French
Revolution which leads to the popular
election of Napoleon Bonaparte's nephew
Napoleon Bonaparte's nephew Louie
Napoleon Bonaparte this guy right over
here but France is still not done it
still can't establish itself as a
long-lasting republic in 1851 this
character declares himself Emperor
so 1851 he too declares himself Emperor
and Napoleon and France is not finally
freed of kings and emperors until 1870
until 1870 so this let's do this run all
the way to 1870 where France essentially
loses the franco-prussian war and this
character this character right over here
is deposed and you have the
establishment of the third French
Republic